What's going on people?
Kevin Hart here.
And we are at Baddies Comedy Co.
Obviously, I'm not
here by myself.
I'm with some
talented comedians,
Greg Coleman, Earl Elliot, Bruce
Leroy Williams, and Ali Sultan.
Take 1.
Where you from, Ali?
Well, live in Minneapolis.
But I moved here 13--
13 years ago from Yemen.
How long you
been doing comedy?
I attempted it
seven years ago.
But I've been active
for the last five years.
Define that, so
people can understand.
Like when say active.
So the first year, I
did like seven open mic.
That doesn't help at all.
You don't learn anything from
going up seven times a year.
You have to do at least
seven times a week,
I think, to just get started.
So what inspired you
to start doing stand up?
Did somebody else help
push you in that direction?
Or were you like, you know what?
I just want to give it a shot.
I always wanted to
be a stand up as a kid.
But I grew up in a
athletic house, man.
I had uncles pro ball.
My father was a pro ball player.
Did they you look
at you like yeah,
man, you ain't repping
the family name.
We be out there.
We-- we play ball.
I mean--
Quit telling jokes, sucker.
- He was a punter.
- OK.
Oh, shit.
Oh, Jesus.
He was the first
black punter in the NFL.
So it wasn't like--
he wasn't like a linebacker.
You know, what I mean?
That's tough.
Because eventually, you
got to call him out.
Dad, you-- you the
fucking punter.
Stop talking like you was
our there laying the hat.
If you had to describe
your style of comedy,
what would it be?
Majority of the people in the
world grow up in a struggle.
And that's what I talk
about, growing up struggling.
OK.
I quit my job, not
knowing that any of this
was gonna happen.
Today marks two months--
Two months?
Being out, being
an entrepreneur.
We fre-- we fresh
off the system
Oh, super fresh.
Super fresh.
Do you feel like it's
important for an audience
to leave understanding
who you guys are?
Very much so.
Or would you rather an
audience leave just saying,
oh my god, he was the
funniest person ever?
I don't do it for them.
I do it for me.
KEVIN HART: OK.
Does that make sense?
Like if-- if I
worked at a bank, I'd
be sitting outside talking to
myself, smoking a cigarette,
looking like a crazy person.
So I go on stage.
That's where-- that's for me.
And if they like
it, they like it.
What does this
moment mean to you?
Oh, man, it's--
it's literally history,
because no one has ever
been on TV from my country--
KEVIN HART: OK.
Who has not been like on an
FBI, like, most wanted show.
I'm excited to see you
guys perform tonight.
I'm here to support a man.
So without further ado,
let's get to it, man.